[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Virginie Legrand je
suis chef à domicile dans toute
l'Île-de-France et je vais vous
présenter aujourd'hui une recette de
saison assez accessible très simple et
délicieuse
[Musique]
on va éplucher la pomme
si vous faites ça donc pour un apéritif
par exemple avec des amis faites-le
vraiment au dernier moment sinon la
pomme va s'oxyder on va couper ça en
brunoise petit dés d'un millimètre
[Musique]
donc j'ajoute ça au saumon fumé alors le
saumon fumé c'est mon poissonnier qui
m'a préparé du saumon fumé à la ficelle
donc du coup j'ai pu faire des
dés alors pour la vinaigrette j'ai
mélangé huile d'olive huile de sésame
vinaigre de framboise
vous mettez ça dans des petits
récipients après si vous voulez le faire
en format entrée vous mettez dans une
assiette avec un emporte-pièce
j'ai préparé
une chantilly au curcuma alors la
chantilly petite astuce si vous voulez
faire le chantier maison alors que ce
soit salé ou sucré toujours prendre de
la crème liquide entière sinon elle ne
foisonne pas c'est à dire qu'elle ne
monte pas et elle ne double pas
[Musique]
donc là j'ai juste mis crème liquide
curcuma sel poivre
pour le dressage on rajoute des petits
œufs de truite
voilà et des perles de citron
pour le côté acide
donc 16 de citron vert
on peut mettre une petite touche de
curcuma pour le rappel
et on termine avec des petites touches
d'aneth
alors voilà pour vous j'ai réalisé cette
recette de petites pièces apéritives à
base de saumon fumé grenade pomme granny
une chantilly au curcuma les œufs de
truite vous les trouvez en supermarché
et les perles de citron vous les
trouverez sur Internet pour les
professionnels mais vous pouvez vous
amateurs gourmand vous les procurer bon
appétit